[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert breer senior nfl reporter for the
monday morning quarterback joining us on
the program all right you're unbiased
perch last night watching this game with
the taunting call what did you make of
that albert
i mean i i think it's ridiculous the way
they're calling these um
you know i could cassius marsh have done
a little bit more to prevent that
situation for himself i mean the flying
leg kick and then just sort of stare
down on the other sideline
i mean you know like i think if you're
um you're matt naggy today you're
probably telling your players in a
teaching point like
i don't agree with the rule but like if
they're calling this just you know if
you're going to celebrate don't make eye
contact with anybody in the opponent you
know what i mean like so
um you know i do i think cassius marsh
did everything he could to avoid it no
but like you add it to kind of the the
hip check there which i'm sure you've
seen that
um and everything else it just
like it just feels like this is not
being consistently enforced across the
league and it feels like and i i go look
going into the season dan i really
thought like
this is going to take him two three four
weeks to to work it out and to figure
out where that line is
and here we are and it's week nine and
it still feels like people don't have a
full understanding of what's going to
get called and what isn't going to get
called okay but it felt like tony
corenti the official yeah initiated some
contact here with no it did and plus he
doesn't throw the flag
where there is an obvious taunt but then
he throws it like right after they you
know
nudge into one another like now it was
retaliation yes i it felt like he missed
the taunting penalty and then almost
waited
and then threw the flag after you know
they they made contact with one another
yeah and if you're the league the last
thing you can do
is have the
have the idea out there that your
officials are engaging in anything that
becomes in any way personal at all with
any player or coach right
like they're they're supposed to be the
ones that are out there that are not
emotional that are looking at the game
from a down the middle perspective
and aren't letting anything anybody says
get to them
and yeah i mean it
i don't know if there was some sort of
altercation between marsh and the
official and tony earlier in the game
um or if like just tony got his backup
about like the flying leg kick and stare
down but like it did feel like there was
something personal there because it
absolutely looked intentional and
um look the league's had a lot of
problems with officiating the last
couple of years um you know and and i
think that there's a little bit more to
al river on you know winding up out than
than met the eye and
um it just it feels to me like this is
something they can't just let it go you
know does the nfl respond today
like they don't always respond right
away
um but they might get it out there the
way the nfl would respond in a situation
like this normally if it were a player
right is they would say we're looking
into it right like so they would at
least get it out there and let the
public know this is something we're not
like just brushing over we're looking
into it and then usually with the
players the way it works is that by the
end of the week they've sent the fedex
out to the guy
and
that at that point the news gets out of
whatever happened to the player or coach
whoever was involved in it and so like
you would think that it would probably
be the same process here where the nfl
gets something out on tony corenti say
we're looking into this and we're
talking to him about this
um and then if there was gonna be any
sort of sanctions i think they'd
probably be later in the week after they
talk to everybody what happens to mac
jones after the uh
shoestring tackle
um
leg twists like yeah
i mean you know what's funny is like he
comes off as
like he almost comes off as like opie in
his press conferences you know i mean
like you hear him talk publicly and he
just seems like you're
like i don't know any better way to put
it then like kind of like sounds like
he's stoned when he talks you know what
i mean like and so he seems very kind of
like passive but you hear all these
legendary stories about how competitive
he is right like in
um you know i remember talking to some
scouts in the spring about how
um you know the alabama people would
tell him he would get into it with nick
saban when he was running the scout team
and like yell like trash talked nick
saban about the way his defense was
playing against mack who was to his
backup at the time
um and so i think that this is probably
like a combination of
mac not knowing exactly what had
happened because he had just gotten hit
there and probably being a little bit
overly competitive in the moment that
said
the fact that the defensive player was
injured on this play right the fact that
he suffered an ankle injury
i think the nfl has to look at this and
say
if the roles were reversed and a
quarterback got hurt in a play like this
what would happen right
um that's why i think they've got a
problem on their hands and that's why i
think they probably have to find mac
jones because
that'd be a legal play
that would be illegal play if brian
burns had the ball in his hands but he
didn't
and the twist at the end i think you
could certainly say mack had enough time
there while he was on the ground to
figure out seeing people running past
him that brian burns probably didn't
have the ball
odell beckham jr does he find out where
he's going today
i don't think he gets claimed today um
and i could be wrong about that but you
know for another team to claim him at
this point um it's 7.25 million dollars
they have a settlement agreement with
the browns where he'll um you know like
he gets termination pain i don't get the
weeds in it but he gives 3 million back
to the browns if um you know if he winds
up clearing waivers um i think he
probably
will not get claimed i mean there are a
couple teams in there
that are on that list that have enough
money to claim them that are sort of
interesting to me um the one that you
really look at is seattle just because
pete carroll's already addressed it
publicly
um you know they've tried to show
russell wilson like we're all in for you
to to make it happen with you right now
and i think the seahawks have to reckon
with the possibility too that this might
be it for them with russell wilson right
like and so
if this is it for them with russell
wilson what's the harm in going and you
know burning the cap space that you have
on a player that's gonna you know be his
best and so you know then you kind of
create a situation where it's like okay
like we're making one great run with
russell wilson here
and maybe there's a long-term benefit
where if you wind up making a real run
you know he's convinced that he wants to
stay there longer than just the rest of
this year okay explain this to me that
odell beckham jr is not good for the
browns but odell beckham jr is good for
seattle
i think it has everything to do with the
power of the quarterback okay and
i
i know the browns firmly believe this i
believe it too
baker mayfield got better last year
after odell went down
and baker mayfield playing really well
on sunday against the bengals they don't
view that as a as as a
as an accident either like baker
mayfield's at his best when he can go
out there and play point guard right
and like when he can go out there and
see the field and you and all five guys
are live in the route and he doesn't
have to look over every three or four
plays to make sure that odell beckham's
not losing his mind because he's not
getting the ball and that's bad for a
young quarterback right why is russell
wilson going to be better for odell
because
it's the same thing as tom brady with
randy moss like that was the problem
with randy moss earlier in his career
with young quarterbacks right then he
got to new england and the quarterback
was a bigger star than he is okay and
the quarterback being a bigger star than
he is i think made a made a big
difference because now it's like i like
randy moss could legitimately go into
new england and say i know this guy
knows more than me i know this guy has
been to the mountaintop this guy's a
bigger star than i am so in this
situation it's on me to fit in with him
not the other way around and i think
russell wilson probably has that sort of
like that has that sort of
like i guess leverage is the right word
in a relationship with his receivers
whereas a baker mayfield doesn't you
know a baker mayfield if odell's not
getting the ball and he's not happy
he's not going to point the finger to
himself if that happens with russell
wilson i think the dynamic is completely
different and that's why i think like
you know you even look at like when the
patriots got rid of randy moss that was
why because it sort of reverted to that
and that i think that's what every team
that's considering signing him or
claiming him has to take into account is
what sort of effect it's going to have
on your quarterback and whether or not
your quarterback has the power to
leverage the right
the right sort of attitude out of odell
beckham how does aaron rodgers play
against seattle this weekend
i think he's like at his best when he's
like in fu mode right like and i think
like i mean nobody how does he get to
the point where he's allowed to play not
how does he play do you think he's
playing against seattle i do okay yeah i
mean and look like i will say this i
mean 100
like this is
like if he has symptoms whatever i don't
know about that right like that's
possible that you know like the timing
doesn't like he has another positive
test whatever right like so
he's got to get through the protocols
first but i think if he clears on
saturday
then i think he's going to play and just
having talked to packers coaches about
this over the last few days
i i can tell you unequivocally if they
one of them said to me if there's anyone
in the league who can play without
practicing during the week it's aaron
rodgers and so you know they're going to
get aaron rodgers ready to play um you
know over the next few days
and i think where this would have gotten
interesting dan
is if jordan love had played really well
against the chiefs maybe
organizationally then they might say
let's get a second look at him you know
if they win that game maybe they have a
little more breathing room now
let's take another look at what jordan
love looks like out here we can gather
some valuable information and we can
give aaron the benefit of another week
off
but i think based on the way jordan the
way jordan love played now like kind of
the urgency of the situation the packers
are facing
they're going to do everything they can
to get him ready i think he's going to
start on sunday so long as he clears the
protocols
does this affect his status long term
with the packers in your opinion
i think yes um
their handling of this situation
is
going to be really important now the
league's investigating this right so
they're requesting all the video
and they're like trying to gather every
piece of
like every piece of information they can
about the way this went over the last
three months
i think you know one of the one of the
interesting pieces of this is the press
conference piece of it where
like the packers if you look at the way
they handle the press conferences right
you can tell what happened there like
you don't need me to tell you they put
every other unvaccinated player on zoom
every single other unvaccinate player
was on zoom only aaron rodgers was going
to
go into the podium without without a
mask on
so the packers can very easily say to
the league we told him look like every
other play everyone every other one of
our guys
is is up there right
so how do they handle this now do they
fall on the sword and say you can talk
to aaron we've got our players back
or do they say look at the way we handle
every other one of our players i think
that right there
because aaron takes everything so
personally i think that right there is
important because if aaron feels like
he's being thrown under the bus by the
by the packers all that good well over
the three last three months i think goes
out the window if the packers fall on
the sword here
maybe it helps them right like if the
packers show we have your back like hey
aaron look we traded for randall cobb we
went and got whitney merciless and
jaylen smith in the middle of the season
we're we're acting in a different way
we're winning with you and now we have
your back
when you're in a really kind of tough
spot i think that could end up going a a
a long way so i don't think it's like
how like the on-field piece goes i think
it's how the nfl investing investigation
goes that could really wind up affecting
where that relationship is when we get
to february and march thank you albert
uh we appreciate your time as always
you got it dan that's albert breer
senior nfl reporter and lead strategist
for monday morning quarterback